uh
we're playing games so is apple vs
preach
and uh yeah this is uh abba i'm preach
we'll see in the back and we have gp
on the board so yeah what are we doing
today the game today we're revisiting
crimes
in florida oh yes all right we got
florida crimes we got a brand new list
of florida crimes fresh
this time you're gonna guess whether
it's a male or a female who comes in
okay okay all right
gender violence
um hit me up fam here we go
these are all real i hope i looked i
didn't look super deeply into everyone
but bro with florida you know it's
florida it's florida exactly
uh okay so this is during covet keep in
mind this happened this is uh
uh mid-2020.
uh a person
spat on all of the groceries in a publix
grocery store that's a woman
[Music]
that's a woman preach says woman abba
all right okay that's a woman you are
correct
i don't know why why
i don't know why but she said spit on
groceries i'm like that sounds like
something a woman would do yeah just
groceries yes that's a karen that didn't
want to put a mask on
yeah
she's
she spat on the groceries she was caught
on camera spitting on on on produce
specifically fruits and vegetables god
damn
and then when they caught her and asked
her why she goes i don't know
god damn nah i see that that's the kind
of stuff i'm like
why
what was the purpose of all of this
and normally lucky that they caught her
on camera she just she just said i like
ruined people's day you just most of
those cameras don't even have people
watching the feeds no of course not so
[ __ ] that like they would happen they're
not going to review footage so it's
probably people spitting on stuff all
the time you know what i said the other
day what did you see the other day i was
i was grabbing an avocado to see if it
was ripe or not i was just like rubbing
it then i threw it back in there and i'm
like is that inappropriate
it's not inappropriate i mean you're
supposed to you're supposed to [ __ ]
know if it's ripe or not i mean kovid
has all this thing going on that is like
feeling some type of way about touching
[ __ ] how am i supposed to know if it's
ripe especially avocados you can't know
i agree but i think because of cover
everyone's become so anal about hey
problems in proximity that just like me
touching it i look around just to see if
anyone sees me touching oh no start
rubbing
i have to start rubbing go ahead i think
cause an avocado you don't you don't eat
the outside at all right
an apple might be a different story wash
the sheet but you generally wash it wash
the [ __ ] just just wash your stuff you
know i mean
so
yeah
people are getting crazy about this
what's the better thing what's the
alternative i want to check for avocados
oh well put it in my pocket i don't want
it but i can't put it back so i'm not
buying i'm not buying it that's true
yeah i don't think there's any other way
to tell if it's ripe or not i think with
avocados such a short window before
they're trashed yeah these [ __ ]
are like you got 10 minutes bro yeah
yeah yeah 10 minutes avocados are fickle
as hell bro 10 minute window and then
they age like white women they just like
so quick there's a peak and then it just
dies
[Laughter]
avocado that prime is legit
oh my god
they're gonna hate you for this yeah
yeah yeah
see that's why you were bullied
it's okay i allow white women with me to
say [ __ ] in bed so
they get some privileges
no you don't
anyways what's the next one
oh my god he said avocado aged like
white woman god damn they're the white
wingman fruits
and veggies
that's a very good point
oh my god
if you have to assign races to each
fruit would you would you go
a
erase the each fruit yes
i feel like pears are asian for some
reason
i don't know they give me an asiany vibe
apparently
what's the shape you look at a pear
you're like some chinese [ __ ] right now
it's
you said they aged like white women let
this man go chinese is wild bro and
pears aged pretty well you could keep a
pair for a while until until when it
ages it ages ages quick that's right
you see
i have added it
oh my god
uh
what's what's with with black
that's a good question
plantain
no
he's just trying to he's just trying to
put some black [ __ ] in there
i don't know what i don't know i really
don't know
it has has to be something that lasts
but when it's [ __ ] it's really [ __ ]
you know yeah
like
what it's awesome for what it's like no
way i don't know
yeah because you know black don't crack
except when we do crack
it's a good question because we do crack
thanksgiving
that's a good question i don't know
but anyways i like pears so we'll just
stick with that okay
black on crack
asian
asian state blazing i don't know
all right all right next one
uh
somebody stabbed their partner in the
head with a fork because uh their potato
was undercooked
several times in the head with a fork
that's a man
that's a woman that's a man i like that
we split it that's a woman that's a man
that was a man stabbing his wife yes
that's a man that's a listen there's
some dudes but
[ __ ] tuna casserole they just stab
their wives you know what it's christ in
the head with a foreign
where's my can opener [ __ ] and he just
smells like there's some dudes who just
crazy that sounded like
my potato is not fully cooked [ __ ]
that that's just dudes who are like that
yeah i want to say man but i just want
to have this no that that was that
wasn't that doesn't matter
an undercooked potato does suck i'm not
defending i'm not defending domestic
abuse but have you ever had an
undercooked potato it's upsetting dude
it is upsetting we have to bite into it
as a crunch you're like oh this shit's
still raw oh wow you're getting a fork
in the head that's not what you're
thinking no i mean maybe not that
that must have been the boiling point
you know what i'm saying
the boiling point they didn't cook the
potatoes certainly did not
the
the proverbial potato that broke the
camel's back you know what i'm saying
like
that's just i don't know for me
for me it's like you ever look forward
to a meal and you find out a part of
it's undercooked yeah
it's pretty upsetting that it could ruin
a whole evening but not not enough to
fork a [ __ ] in the head
that's crazy that's crazy dog hold up
let me see you're gonna fork a whole
[ __ ] in the head because your
[ __ ] is not uncooked god damn you're
just gonna thanks too it's not like a
reaction where he's like oh [ __ ] i just
stabbed my wife for the fork he was like
did she die and again no uh she just had
she sustained some head drama and he was
charged with uh aggravated assault
with the deadly weapon god damn
that is wild
you know what i think that conversation
went out like
what
she gave him the potatoes he starts
biting into it and she's like what's
wrong it's like the potatoes aren't
cooked she's like well what do you mean
it's like they're hard it's like i don't
get it it's like like this and starts
stabbing them
oh my god
listen
on our way here we had a conversation in
the car okay
because we were reviewing another video
where it was a video about a man in a
wheelchair uh getting shot eight times
by the time right by the cops
and then i thought i just said oh [ __ ]
the cops involved who got shot and he
said a guy in a wheelchair and i said oh
[ __ ] they see me rolling
oh wait a minute remix they see me wrong
and it's pretty [ __ ] brutal but
comedy [ __ ] ruined me because i'll
find anything funny in anything yeah i
realize that i don't have the same
sensibilities of other people when it
comes to like
comedic stuff or anything like that it
could be really [ __ ] up and if it's
done creatively enough i can't help but
laugh yes it's like even racist comments
yes even racist comments like i be
laughing sometimes because i'm like
i'm like wow i never i never heard that
one before
and i'm gonna be like
that was pretty creative yeah you you
went the creative route yeah good job
good on you yeah yeah
that's why i find once you start doing
comedy it's very hard to have friends
outside of the comedy yes you're fine
yes
you can still maintain friendships
because then you see some of my favorite
people to talk to because i'm like
i could say anything to you guys you're
not going to be like yo like you you
know if i say something stupid but like
you won't be like oh did you hear what
yeah oh my god about that was a line
you know like there was a time oh you go
ahead yeah but you know that's an
interesting thing that that whole thing
because
i don't know if you're also like this
i'm pretty protective of the title
comedian in that if you're not really a
comedian and you try to use that veil
like i don't give you the benefit of the
doubt yeah when i go to an open mic for
example i will listen to some people do
like straight up just racism on stage
yes okay
and if i don't think that they're even
attempting a joke i look at them funny
yeah if i see you or at least attempting
humor
okay then i'm like you know what maybe i
should yeah but abby what's the
difference the process i guess the
process i think there's nuance it's not
easy it's not always a clear line
sometimes people are like well how do
you determine i'm like listen i'm not
gonna be honest with you i can't say 100
yeah i can't say what i'm perceiving but
generally comics are pretty good
about giving people the benefit right
because we try really tough stuff that
sometimes really doesn't land or is
really edgy and divides people
completely yeah right so
um
i think i give people that chance and
then even if i don't like the joke if i
see that there was an attempt then i'm
like whatever like i don't really care
also this is gonna sound [ __ ] up i'm
not against racist jokes
i'm not either
you know what i mean like even if i
think the joke is hacky yeah and i don't
really rock with it
i'm fine with people being able to do
them
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah
definitely and
yeah i think like that's the
conversation coming up a lot lately
because you know sometimes you'll you'll
see people who are like political
commentators
and they'll be like oh you know it's
just comedy and i'm like
i'll give you the benefit of the doubt
sure but i don't record the same benefit
to you that i would a stand-up comedian
in a comedian context you guys you guys
get what i'm talking about
you know i don't think you're crazy the
context is really something telling like
if it's not if it was the context of a
comedy i'm gonna be like
okay the point is to get laughs or
get laughed with discomfort or whatever
we're not you're supposed to get laughs
right i get that yeah
if it's not that or there was no like
i'm not
it's not so much if the joke is funny or
not it's really if
there was
a
process in which we're trying to do if
there was a way you were going with the
joke if that i could see which we're
going if i'm just like there was no
premise there was there was no elements
of comedy right there was no punch there
was no premise you just said some racist
[ __ ] yeah
that's not comedy yeah
it's saying some racist [ __ ]
so
yeah where's the line i think it's just
it's a case-by-case basis exactly you
know like yeah cool and if you can't try
stuff
that's
i for lack of a better term edgy it's
hard to get to that level where you can
construct a really good joke you know
what comes to mind very it ties into the
last thing stabbing someone with a fork
because of an overcooked thing
schultz has a really really really good
joke i [ __ ] find it hilarious and i'm
sure this was tough to
uh to work on and do yeah but
essentially the premise is like
ethnic food is so good because like
there's no women's rights
you know it's like so like you know like
that you know once the
when maria overcooks the lasagna you
know like tables are getting flipped and
it's like [ __ ] murray so next time
it's like oh man it's beautiful
depression
and he talks about like you know so the
premise is like the cultures that are
he's like middle eastern food have you
tried that [ __ ] amazing women's rights
you know if you tried swedish food that
[ __ ] is garbage
i think that's super funny but i'm sure
like people really pulled back probably
when he yeah definitely but there is
there is
is the point of that joke is not to be
sexist or racist
the point of that joke is to actually
pinpoint that
in some certain countries there is still
that going on that's how i see it you
know i mean this is it's talking about
abuse that is still going on you know
one thing i think people make a mistake
of and i think
this is an issue with it is
people go to a comedy show sometimes
thinking they're going to hear some
truth
and my general experience with comedy
and comedians in general is like they
will stretch facts they will omit things
from a story they'll
exaggerate or make up details to get to
a punch line at times
right it's a hip-hop concert yeah it's
like it's like and i think folks
sometimes don't understand that it's
like sometimes people be like well does
dave chappelle got his facts wrong in
his last special i'm like breath
this is nice it's just national
geographic
like you should not and that's why
the same way i don't take it very
seriously when they get it wrong i also
don't take it too seriously when they
get it right i don't generally look at
me personally i don't look at comedians
be like the other truth sayers who you
know i'm just like ref this is just
funny and maybe there's a nugget in
that's an interesting observation right
but
i think people have to stop
deconstructing comedy and stand up as
political commentary all the time
oh my god anna gatsby had
all her facts right yeah that [ __ ] was
not funny
the point was to be funny
you missed the point you were factual
not funny yeah so
all right cool she's fine i don't know
if you can even say she was factual it's
just a perspective and you know what
there was an attempt to be funny there
so i don't even get mad at her i find it
cringe when people go in there like
[ __ ]
revolutionary uh you know standing up
for women's rights i'm like stand up con
i'm like bruh
just go to the show enjoy some last
maybe there's some like controversial
stuff but if you come out of there
having your like whole political stances
changed then i think you're going at
comedy the wrong way because you're not
recognizing the comics are lying about
facts they're making up [ __ ] they're
obfuscating things that are important to
the story
but they're not journalists so it
doesn't matter they really look at
comics
like they're like
yeah or when they look at jon stewart
it's like it's not the same thing
jon stewart on stage is not the same as
jon stewart trevor noah on stage is not
the same one as said the same thing as
trevor noah when he has as he has a show
right when he has a show he uses comedy
but that's not the point of the show
exactly exactly so i think
the the the the the dissecting of comedy
specials makes me cringe a little bit
yeah because i'm like you're missing the
point of this whole event yeah it's it's
absurdity it's comedy by definition is a
matter of exaggeration it can never be
factually just truth so i don't know
that was just something that i think
really [ __ ] with people's perception
when they hear it because they're
hearing someone talking to a mic you're
like he's lying
it's a performance it's not meant to be
the truth oh my god he's lying he's
drake
it's a performance calm down but it's
the same thing as hip-hop i'm not mad
there's a lot of people that tell
stories and hip-hop that story was
exaggerated and when it's not
exaggerated they go to jail because
that's the evidence of a crime
how about a week ago yes yes
i think that's like the big problem that
folks have and i think that's why folks
are getting caught up in all this stuff
you think it's all the truth same thing
i think hip-hop went to the same thing
yeah but they're telling stories
yeah not theirs they are the stories
they made up
maybe they made it up yeah it doesn't
matter yeah
anyways it's entertainment what else do
we have
speaking of entertainment
um
somebody hit their part after an
argument hit their partner slap their
partner in the face with a burrito and
was charged with domestic battery
someone slapped their partner with a
burrito yeah
after an argument that's the man what
was the argument over
uncooked burrito it doesn't say or i
didn't write it down it's not the person
does it say where any other details
it's all florida it was uh at home this
is all florida but it was in
in their home
was it a home cooked burrito from
takeout
i believe was from takeout
that's a man i think that's a woman
it's divided again
that was a man
i i would have thought that was a woman
so i found it was i'm trying to i'm
trying to throw it off you know yeah no
i could definitely see it being a man
but for some reason i thought the man
brought take out and the bishops lost
her mind but generally when it comes to
like throwing food and stuff like that
that's more a man's thing
throwing food throwing food
stabbing i disagree stabbing man
throwing food
woman
they throw drinks at you they flip their
plates they throwing food that shouldn't
really woman mike's birthday's has been
it sounds like someone's had some
ketchup in their face
change your [ __ ] tone no i'm good
with that if you know i find generally
like dudes who lose their minds they'd
be maybe maybe just chucking food at it
they'd be losing their minds over
domestic stuff i'm good i'm good i don't
know it's not something i've experienced
that i've i've experienced but i've seen
that have you seen it
i in bars
yeah but it was at home
that's why i said at home oh maybe
yeah at home i would expect it to but i
don't know they throw empty plates but
not from food i don't know
there is a lot when you go through
florida crimes when you really dig
there's a lot of food throwing i'm gonna
be honest i only have to pick a few and
i will say it seems pretty split it's
hard to say which one is right yeah
there was a woman who there was a woman
who threw butter at her sister and then
was charged with battery was the boy
with buttery
uh she was trying butter was like hard
to play she was
hardly what shot message
because she called the police and said i
got butter all over me so if it was hard
i don't know if it would have like
leaked on her that's a good question
it's florida it was probably because if
it's warm butter that's dangerous
but warm butter you burn butter yeah hot
butter is
sorry warm i meant hot like on the pan
yeah that's [ __ ] dangerous yeah i'm
just trying to burn them yeah that's
crazy yeah that's oily like that's my
whole point that's it you got charged
with buttery
[Laughter]
somebody tried using a one dollar coupon
at walmart the coupon was invalid
uh so this person slammed the shopping
cart into workers and then ran to the
car grabbed a gun
and pointed it at the employees before
being tased
that's a woman for a coupon
that's
one listen one thing i've learned about
coupons is like that's women
that's women like i don't know what
there's like even a show for coupons
yeah couponing extreme couponing yeah
like there's people like
they've been getting whole ass orders
like four five hundred dollars worth of
orders zero dollars yeah they know
there's a there's a there's a science of
this [ __ ] and every episode i ever saw
there was not a single band
i don't know that's sexist i don't know
what it is okay i don't know if we need
equal outcomes and we need to start
getting minute [ __ ] couponing but
you're not going to see it no
why do you think that is
you know what i think it is what do you
think it is can't be bothered
i can't be bothered either i can't be
bothered to like accumulate this stuff
and repeat
you mean i'm going to have to make
bricolage you know yeah i'm going to
make [ __ ] hearts and crafts to cut to
cut coupons and gather that [ __ ] and
make calculation bruh i'm not good at
math i don't want to do no arts and
crafts and i got to do all those things
to save a couple of bucks let me pay
so
feel me on this
men like to cut corners women like to
save money
yeah
which woman to fill in
you said what you said
can you elaborate
we like to things to be done in an
effective way and fast
they like to save money so what i'm
basically what it really comes down to
is like
men like women women like security
that's another way of saying right the
coupons
are a secure way to get money off
they save that money perfect
i'm gonna get corners i'ma get more
money yes dudes will use hookups dudes
will [ __ ] build for the whatever
right
ladies won't go down that route
generally speaking we're speaking
valleys of course but couponing is safe
secure it just requires some strategy
i'm pretty sure i bet my money on it
women are better at saving their money
than men are
jamie jamie can you google that
jamie
you're trying to mimic [ __ ] uh
that's jp
not jamie jamie that's andrew schultz
has a jamie we have a jp no
yes he has the [ __ ] black guy
alex yeah but jamie doesn't google [ __ ]
who's jamie
we speak for him the white dude
that's he's not jamie i don't know
i know he has a jamie his name is um
he has a french name yeah first name i
made fun of him for it what's the french
good noise or some [ __ ]
no
it's like something gay
[Music]
uh something gay why did you it's yin
no no no no no shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that's not your first name that's my
last name yeah
sing it
just kidding
what's this motherfucker's name who
cares
no no no it's like it literally means
gay the way that they say gay town oh
yeah
yeah hold up that's his last name
huh yeah it's his last name
no no no
i gotta look this up
because now now i'm getting cheesed
when i can't remember something i get
really mad
okay hold up andrew saltz podcast
cast
podcast cast
[ __ ] i can't [ __ ]
all right here we go
i'm gonna see his name and i'm gonna get
mad
you're gonna you won't be able to gagnon
god
gagnon
that's the first name you know his last
name
gagnon got gagnon they said yeah
because they're because he's american
yeah
yeah did you find out if uh if women
save money better
[Music]
really if you look at my face when you
said that i went
really in my experience
i'm way better than my girl that's for
sure i'm not better than michael my girl
is way better than me but my girls are
super [ __ ] genius men are more prone
to risky behavior when it comes to
finances yes
that's me
yeah but i'm also 80d so right which is
a in 80d there's
we do more
erratic and
like spontaneous things right yeah which
is good for comedy too though i think
it's great for comedy oh when i let my
brain when i let my 80d brain like
that's why i get the best
the best content the best things the
best things about for this these videos
when i go off that's my 80d brain oh my
god what's wrong with you yo that's why
these hoes is on sugar baby sites
yes they don't know how to save their
money
hey you know what these all make sense i
was like yo why do we have an epidemic
of sugar babies
because they don't have to
that's like all these people aren't
seeking a rage i didn't get it
don't y'all save your money that's the
thing we just get the money and you know
what i also didn't consider women are
much larger consumers than men are
i know
like in terms of spending credit card
buying clothes all this stuff like it's
all catered to women because women spend
way more money than men do so i just you
know what
yeah i'm wrong but i spend i don't
necessarily spend more than my girl
yeah it's just that i can spend more to
my girl so i do
but my my girl's pretty safe with her
money
she's smart with it too yeah well she's
a financial planner or some [ __ ] does
she work at a bank she's an analyst i
think that's for jobs
no but i mean
she was like that she's not like that
because of the bank she works at a bank
because she's like that yes okay okay
you know chicken before the egg
something like that but she's like that
but yeah yeah she's been like that okay
okay anyways
next up yeah absolutely that was a
female i think that was an obvious one
but it sparked an interesting
conversation but she went and got a gun
god damn karen called one dollar
what
it's expired
like like the story because then she got
just picture getting tased afterwards
for a dollar coupon that pays for a
dollar [ __ ] [ __ ] calm down [ __ ] cake
flavored pop-tarts or whatever
next up what we got boom
uh somebody stop
this one i'm sorry
someone stomped on 16 goose eggs that in
a park in like a public park there were
16 goose eggs and someone just stomped
on them
that's a whole that's a man
that's a homeless man that's a man he's
a homeless man yeah is he homeless
it was a woman and i don't believe she
was homeless
you sure she wasn't homeless
i'm not a hundred percent sure i kind of
just wrote the quickly what yeah what
did she why'd she do it
uh she was asked about it she was asked
about it
and she said uh they looked rotten to me
that's homeless
that's homeless and i feel like if
you're homeless you could be a man or a
woman it's the same thing
yeah there's there's homeless people
haven't it's just like they're not
gender listen i'm a male
okay
but then once i'm homeless i'm just
homeless
my gender and sex become very secondary
to my
yeah exactly exactly like if i meet a
homeless girl like once you start
smelling like pissing like homelessness
it's just like you no longer a part of
that gender for me
you could be the hottest homeless [ __ ]
that's funny because the police think
exactly like that for black people right
all right cool
once you black you just a
[Laughter]
thing carry on
no
too soon too far
all right
no comment i got nothing
uh
okay somebody left
their kids aged three and five
in their pickup truck and then went to
go have a beer at their local strip club
i wish it was a woman someone followed
yeah i wish it was a woman that's a man
your wish will come true
it's true it's a woman yeah it was a
woman yeah i was surprised by that too
i don't even know why she's such a
degenerate but that's [ __ ] up
i'm just going to go to the strip club
get myself a beer
and someone called the cops saw the kids
in the alone in the pickup truck well if
you're at the [ __ ] parking lot of the
strip club and there's two kids chilling
in the back of your pickup truck yeah
you're gonna call the cup like wow
there's [ __ ] are probably
thinking wow
there's a stripper wallet in there she
really didn't have a babysitter
and she needed to go so but that's not
one of them she just wanted a beer
i mean there's so many things wrong with
that do you why kids overheating
you're in a strip club it's like
for a beer
yeah
to ask just have a beer at home look at
some titties on your phone or something
like the beer at home is going to be
less expensive than at the strip club
but what are you doing but you know what
every time i hear about [ __ ] up
stories like this i'm like i think this
is like a great orange story for like a
really famous person
like the child or the lady yeah it's
like you know we're living in such soft
times i think sometimes people who grow
up in these [ __ ] up homes is terrible
let's all agree but they make the best
artists
but that's a great stand-up story i'm
sorry that's crazy my mom left me in a
pickup truck so she could have a beer at
a strip club
and we got to see some titties that
night just like i could just see it
going so many places for good stories
whatever i digress
that's an interesting story that's crazy
that's a great story yeah
you know it's like i got assaulted when
i was in the third grade terrible but it
makes for a really interesting story
that's just yeah absolutely yeah
and nobody want to hear about [ __ ]
liam who lived in the suburbs and went
to the park every day with his best
friend brett so i went to uh i went to
school and my life was amazing
we got bb guns and we shoot him at birds
[Laughter]
[Music]
what else we got
uh somebody was caught smearing feces in
a gym sauna and peeing on the rocks
peeing standing city
was that stained city
that's a man
smearing feces in a sauna yeah
in like hidden places you know
that's the pettiness of a woman
uh i'm going with a man that's the
pettiness of a woman some happen nah i'm
going with the man some happened i think
i think the dude was just a little bit
bored yeah possible
yeah i think you're right so it was a
guy oh wow yeah why do you do it
uh
there was no info on that i think he was
just [ __ ] around trying to be a prank
you know uh
type what are those guys what are those
guys with the prank movies
oh jackie jackass trying to do a jackass
type thing that's a jackass style thing
to do so we're pissing in the rocks
that's bad bro
physical rocks feels great though
like pit like when you when you're out
and you're taking a piss and you really
need to go
okay it has nothing to do with rocks
specifically rocks because what you said
was like pissing on rocks feels great
and i was just imagining you like okay
yeah yeah yeah
i've pissed on rocks before and there's
something satisfying about watching the
rock change colors
get darker yeah yeah i can see that yeah
yeah that's a thing
that's a thing
if you've never peed on a rock before
and watched it go from like light gray
to like dark gray
that's just fire
i'm pretty sure there's a r kelly joke
in there
i remember peeing on rocks in my younger
years i remember taking pride because i
would try to spray to hit all the rocks
dead ass
that's not even a joke
i used to pee on rocks
you were a weird mother
i was [ __ ] choking
this brought back repressed memories i
used to pee on rocks
and i remember there was i i i it just i
i remember this in like 20 years
last time i remember is when i did it
but going back to my memories i used to
pee on rocks
and i enjoy changing the colors
there's not very few things that you can
pee in that will have that kind of
effect
just say a girl's weave
shout out to our kelly all right i found
it let's go even though it won't change
color it will no no hair gets darker
what if it's the color of a rock you
know
[Music]
the floor is concrete keep your [ __ ] in
your pants it won't change the color
though it's not the same
rocks absorb water differently are we
still talking about peeing on rocks yeah
i was just saying i just wanted to make
that clear the feces was going too far
but the peeing on the pee on the rocks
it's just the smell of it because it's
not just it's you're interested can you
smell it yeah it's hot rocks that's what
it means
that's what makes it more than a sauna
is it that bad yes it is
i'm unaware that yeah every far you ever
fart in in in your in your in your bath
that i don't know
i just thought saunas because of the
fumes you don't you don't no no it's
worse it's worse because now you have
pissed vapor yeah you ever been in the
sauna and a [ __ ] keeps splashing
water on them rocks and you looking at
this [ __ ] like can you stop
splash splash no cause you know the
rocks
to make it hotter and i'm already like
it's hot enough [ __ ] yeah but that's
the thing imagine with piss
yeah so you have all the oh
hey i was unaware man
i was unaware i'm learning jesus christ
we're not doing this all right next up
uh okay somebody i guess this is kind of
a trick one but
somebody fled an aircraft
uh right before i was about to take off
using the emergency slide you know the
emergency slide like when there's like a
water landing i.e when you crash that's
amazing what kind of what kind of
aircraft was it
big-ass aircraft because the emergency
lighting is lighting
them it's on big commercials
it's a commercial flight
they wanted to get off
and they were like um oh but that could
be that's a woman that's a ghost that's
a woman no no way way way way
that could be a woman
i guess it's a trick it's two people
is it a man and a woman and a woman
that's this [ __ ] right here
she'll be two lesbians
two hobbit lesbians that have been
perfect it's a couple and their dog
okay what happened the dog needed to pee
i think the guy was having a panic
attack
okay yeah damn and they and they
wouldn't stop the plane and he was like
[ __ ] this they're just opening the door
and he slid out that is then his wife
followed him and then the dog followed
the map
what about their luggage
that's wild bro
the luggage followed them in jail like
yes if you saw somebody having a panic
attack and the plane was about to take
off would you want the plane to stop to
let them know you just punch them you
knock them out code yeah
punch a [ __ ]
oh wait i got something for you no
and then yeah
yeah you know on one hand you want to
sympathize with somebody's having a pan
attack on the other it's like you [ __ ]
are soft i need to get some places
you need to say what i need to get some
places it's just like i'm in the plane
that's soft bruh but i know i know panic
attacks and that's something that some
people can like actually they can't do
nothing about it but i i i sympathize
with you but i got to go places i got my
whole plane i got things set up i
understand
what you i understand that it's [ __ ]
up but
[ __ ] you i got places to go
yeah that's just too soft
it is soft
yeah you know i always wonder is it like
really the world is getting soft or were
there always really soft people this
whole time but you just didn't hear
about it all the time or is it the world
getting too brand new
there you go
i don't know i don't know what it is but
i i saw something i'm like really i
understand i've had things like okay
the point about this world is getting
things to be done easy
like it's easier to
to communicate with people it's easier
to cook it's easier to everything is to
improve how things are done so of course
we're going to have less and less
hardships
the things that are hard are going to be
less and less it's not gonna be the same
thing so yeah at some point we're gonna
be solved because it's not gonna be the
same thing there's a few hundred years
back [ __ ] had to do their own
butter have you ever turned butter
[ __ ]
in that thing you have to [ __ ] turn
that's long i don't like buttons so just
to spread butter or to have butter for
your toast or anything like that it
takes you
three days
now
two seconds i could buy that [ __ ] so
yeah everybody's everybody's like do you
think someone that turns butter for
three days to make a kick is gonna have
a panic attack
no man they got other [ __ ] to worry
about but we don't have [ __ ] to worry
really about
so so i just remember when there was a
time where like getting called [ __ ] was
terrifying
yeah and then after that you know the
people was like yeah you are what you
eat i'd rather be a [ __ ] than a dick
and i was just like
i'm just in tune with my emotions it's
like [ __ ] people just own it
they just own everybody own it yeah they
own it yeah i'm not saying no but you
know that's pretty much the general
thing but i do understand that panic
attacks do happen it's not something
that people can control people that have
panic attacks don't want to have panic
attacks
they don't want that [ __ ]
but it can't help it you know what i
mean but if i'm just being my selfish me
i'm like man i got places to go so can
you just not die today
just like whenever you take the metro
and someone just wants to commit suicide
like bruh uh
i'm already late so if you could wait
like
i thought
if you could wait like 15 minutes
people are selfish like that because i
gotta go places
so after me hey um
you best believe [ __ ] just see
somebody jumped up
can somebody clean this nigga's brains
off so we get up with this [ __ ] i got
sex to go to exactly
it's a different ball game like you're
already on the poverty train so
[ __ ] making your life harder is
annoying it's just like bro me out of
all the people you have to [ __ ] with me
yeah i'm the poor dude i'm already poor
i'm not the one that [ __ ] up your life
we got bridges [ __ ] just jump off
[Music]
i'll just jump off why are you making
everybody notice
damn like don't kill yourself what if
you're going to do it jump off the
bridge you see you see what we meant
when we said that you know comedy ruined
us
obviously we'll make it oh yeah it's
coming that's just poverty
poverty made me like hate wasting my
time i already got to take this shitty
[ __ ] train like let's get this [ __ ]
moving i have a joke about that it's
like it's like when i'm on the bus and a
digging in a wheelchair wants to get on
i'm like leave this man
i love that joke because
that's real yeah cause he can lash that
[ __ ] and just go yeah i got whole feet
hey i'm looking at the bus store like
hey [ __ ] i'll slip you some money [ __ ]
just burn
warm speed
we'll say we never saw him
we'll throw some changes
[Music]
this [ __ ] gets off three stops later
you're gonna roll rolling the incline
[ __ ]
so you gotta watch that whole [ __ ] again
in reverse
nah bro that's a poverty of me talking
like
die bro
here's the funny thing ah if the bus
doesn't stop for me [ __ ] them
you'll [ __ ] the whole public transport
system you saw me run again you left
but if the bus stops for other people
i'm like [ __ ] hurry up that's what i'm
saying
that's what i'm saying it's people being
me it's like whatever my friends that
are that are that are driving and like
[ __ ] these [ __ ] pedestrians yeah and
then when they get to walking up she's
like yo yo chill i'm walking
they switch it's all about them it's not
about the situation i agree
what do we have next there's nothing
worse than like working a minimum wage
job taking the bus and then the [ __ ]
bus drives past you yes
it is disheartening yes i've been there
been there done that got the t-shirt
accept it if i'm late
[ __ ] if you early oh yeah i'm i'm i'm
gonna lose my [ __ ] money
i looked at the schedule
i did my job i didn't i looked at you
bro bro cause
oh my god i look at the schedule i'm
gonna get there like three four minutes
early and i'm looking the bus stop is
right there because there's no one at
the bus stop this [ __ ] just
rolls by you gotta wait 40 minutes yeah
yeah
that's some south shore [ __ ]
nah bro that that yeah but i guess we
triggered the [ __ ] out of you that's not
a comedian thing that's a poverty that's
a poverty thing that's awesome i am mad
at you but you're right yeah that that
felt that [ __ ] that's possible when if
you're late you're late but if you're
early and you pass
yeah
i've had it where the bus is late and
because the bus is late
they want to meet their whatever quota
they have to do with time so they just
rip past you yeah
yeah that's infuriating yeah
i'm already late so whoops but i
understand him
if he was already late
you mean you're at the bus stop and he
yeah waiting he's supposed to come at 11
10. 11 15 this guy goes [ __ ] i gotta get
to the terminus yeah 11 20. yeah
yeah
yeah i think i've i've punched bus
shelters before oh absolutely
yeah i've made a gavin of myself and
punch a few a few things yes it's only
gavin's that push
a bunch of walls in in the in the
bedroom
what else we got
so somebody was in a dollar store
they farted
in line the person behind them in line
complained about the fart
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i'm so juvenile
that's funny to me
what the [ __ ] dude yank what happened
the purse so someone's hearted the
person behind them complains yo you
farted what the hell
the person pulls out a knife on them
and then the police are called and that
person is charged with aggravated
assault
that's a man
what is the deadly weapon he's about to
fart
all i know is the individual is black
does it say the race
no i don't know it ah did you have
anything to suspect
i didn't write it down
that's a man that's a man
that's amazing if they're black that's a
man i just wanna see if they're black
that's a man what happened so fart
they're in the dollar store fart in line
aggravated assault they put like floor
well i don't want to give you the
i'm good that's a man
i think it's a woman
it is a woman it's a woman
[ __ ] i could fart if i want to shing
okay okay okay okay
there's a black woman let me
you see that [ __ ] i knew what listen i i
wasn't sure about you as black people
i knew
i could fight if i didn't where i want
to oh my god we're doing the moment
nikki you fart on me [ __ ] yes
i could see a black woman getting mad
about that i don't know why but there's
a person that farted that pulled out the
knife
small points i could see perp did you
fart on me damn well i did and don't
mind if i do again
oh we wild for no reason
damn that's a what what where are they
at lineup it's like a dollar store it's
a dollar store but i remember there was
one time we were in your studio you
farted and i lost my [ __ ]
i was like [ __ ]
did you [ __ ] fart yeah
bruh
hold up hold up hold on hold on can we
appreciate something
only a garbage ass human would fart
behind you and be like i wasn't mean
[ __ ] who else was it
who else was it no but maybe
because we all know people like that who
far beside you trying to look at you
confused like what did he smell me [ __ ]
you don't
you can smell you
no but don't look confused that's what
i'm saying but i didn't think that i
owned it because i know you owned it but
i thought maybe it would have like okay
i was like
maybe it's this chair maybe it's the
floor
some of the chairs make weird noises you
know what i mean frank
i like [ __ ] did you fart and i was
wishing it was i wasn't sure i was
really wishing that [ __ ] wishful thing
did you fart yeah
she's like what
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
god you gotta you gotta be honest we
working this [ __ ] i don't want to smell
your insides but think about it [ __ ] is
wrong with you think about how many
times we filmed it for how long the fact
that i don't do it that often is a sign
of respect
no
no that one time was you know what i'm
saying like
yeah go to the bathroom and the bathroom
is right there get up go in the bathroom
god damn you're working in this [ __ ] i
don't want to be smelling your insides
i'm gonna
look like [ __ ] do y'all remember the
first time y'all y'alls
smelt a woman fart
yeah
wasn't that weird
yeah yeah for sure why is it weird
because i think the way i perceived
women up until that point was like
you never think about women farting and
[ __ ] like obviously you
intellectually you probably know what it
depends on what kind of porn you watch
definitely didn't watch that kind of
point so for me it just wasn't a thing
you know so once i realized that there's
like women can be just as disgusting as
men it really changed my perception yeah
may i maybe linked it to you know what
if you [ __ ] if your [ __ ] could fart
you fart [ __ ] farts are funny
yeah this is the fun part it's
entertainment
for the whole family [ __ ] for the whole
fat dog what is the whole family doing
in there
the [ __ ] is wrong with you what do you
do with your girl hey kids get around
the funny thing that's almost wholesome
i don't know
i agree i think what kills me about
[ __ ] farts is always the women's
reaction afterwards
[Music]
it farts and there's quiet and they go
sorry
every time i always feel terrible about
it
you'll be hitting that [ __ ] from behind
just
sorry i'ma do it again
it's my fault
yeah you sure it sure is your fault you
should have filled this [ __ ] with dick
instead of instead of air hey man
that little pause before is my favorite
you could just hear the attention
sorry
and i've had that happen to me like a
good six seven times really yes
because women are very self-conscious
like have you ever like laughed so hard
because it was just perfect
did you almost lose your you know you
got to like get back into it no because
generally i'm pretty into it so yeah no
i try to replicate if you want to know a
time where i lost my my [ __ ] in bed
because they said something
it hasn't
oh we're about to get a story we're
about to get a story i was in it and you
know sometimes i'd be doing some dirty
talking but nothing too extreme
and uh
remember i said something like you know
that shit's good right and she's like
yeah i'm like
is this the best you ever had she's like
nah not really
[Laughter]
not really
that [ __ ] was so funny oh my god or
wasn't even bad
that's funny i wasn't even mad that's
funny
and i was crying bro that's funny i i
had to stop then at that point i stopped
right
that's just pure comedy right there
that's just pure comedy
not really that's just
had to think back and be like one time
well at least at least she was honest
you know that whatever whenever you said
whenever you said do you like it and she
said yeah she was actually saying the
truth it was just not the best ever
she lives in a great time but honesty is
i've definitely had this
is it the best you ever had no i give it
an eight
hey that [ __ ] had me rolling for days
and i i wasn't bad at all i should kill
guys
that was a good moment that's probably
all the time well queefs generally like
my experience is that women are already
like very self-conscious when they're in
bed or whatever position that they're in
so anything like that that they do they
they feel uncomfortable about it because
they think they've made things worse so
try to be a little bit understanding and
be like not make it awkward just a
question i like to just start calling
them queen laquifa
i don't know why but i've definitely
read this somewhere
queen
i feel like i've heard that somewhere
somewhere okay queen look
okay we look we've heard so many play
play on words with queen yeah yes
i've definitely heard
people talking [ __ ] about her be like
whatever laquifa
oh all right all right let's do one more
cool all right one more let's go yeah
oh man
that's pretty sick
that [ __ ] killed me that's funny
that is funny [ __ ] it was rolling for a
good minute yo that's good
not really
i give it a 8.
you know what the thing is bro it's like
i'm not even mad at that you want to
know why no it's real
that wasn't the best [ __ ] i've ever had
and if a girl asked me is that the best
i'm not going to say yes but i'm saying
it's really good
i'm out of it i'll just find a way to
compliment yeah you know what i'm saying
but it's like
if we're being honest most of the people
that we end up with or that we do [ __ ]
very rarely this is going to be the best
sex we ever had
i am mad at you you know there's always
going to be somebody who [ __ ] you
better or you get [ __ ] you know i mean
like before being honest with yourselves
but that doesn't mean that's essentially
going to be the person you want to be
yeah so for me i think you should
normalize
not having the perfect sex life with
your partner and it's okay there's other
things that compensate for absolutely
and i think if we normalize that i think
that's fine because i'm like you think
you're going to marry the best sexual
partner in your life like bruh
i i don't think most people do you don't
think you will i don't think i will i've
already had the mess up pretty sure
you're pretty sure you're already here
pretty sure we all have that one sex
partner that was just like the [ __ ] was
perfect the way they touched you was
perfect everything was perfect it's just
perfect
really yeah like you're never going to
get a bit but that doesn't mean there's
necessarily a strong emotional
connection or chemistry you don't want
to date relationships there's more to
that yeah i think that's why guys a lot
of the times they'll say
oh crazy [ __ ] is the best [ __ ]
for whatever reason
the best [ __ ] that dudes get is never
the girl that they want to be with
mm-hmm
and i think that's the same for women
too crazy i think that's yeah there's
some people who say like yo i need an
emotional connection to have good sex i
think those people have the best chance
of finding them but for most other
people it's like no the person the
person's going to turn you out to have
you busted 10 nights or your guts all
over the place there's something yeah
it's not going to be the person you
marry there's some exceptions you want
it to be though yeah you'd be you you'd
be rationalizing that shouldn't happen
but it don't work man if i just told her
to shut up forever like
maybe this [ __ ] she lost her mouth
lost her mouth
but not in that way you know i mean not
now yes yeah because you know
what they're mapped to cut them vocal
cords
what you got
all right one last one
so there's two people implicated you
could you could so guess who's gender of
the victim and the perpetrator so this
is at a gym
someone's waiting to use a piece of
equipment i'm not sure which one machine
okay
and um the person is not getting off the
machine
so
someone's just sat they just sat on that
person
as like a form of protest
a woman's hat on a
man okay preach you say woman's head on
man ever i actually think it's the
opposite because i really wanted to be
the opposite yeah
once again
florida's wish is your command
the man set on the woman the man sat on
a woman
the man's side of the woman yeah i
missed florida
i really missed florida yeah
was charges were filed
uh yeah i believe it was um aggravated
sitting invaded assault
yeah that is wow i might be wrong about
that but
that's what i remember because that was
one of the last ones i did
people do we need to get nothing [ __ ]
machines though yeah they do some [ __ ]
be taking their own hogging that [ __ ]
you don't even wipe it down after
they're done it's like [ __ ] who raised
you yeah get the [ __ ] off the machine
hogging that [ __ ] get the [ __ ] off so i
could understand the protesters
[ __ ] like can you get off no
well i'm getting on
no matter what no matter what this
[ __ ] is getting on i'm getting
i'm getting on this [ __ ] too
[Laughter]
all together
oh man all right cool well
that's it for today's uh yeah that's it
for today's episode uh join us for more
stuff and no don't forget to join every
other thing that we have whether it's
the patreon whether it's the other
channel whether it's everything else so
yeah abba vs preach with wasim and jp on
the board